but I shall open
that the whole
flighty so high-level things up
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to my channel I lead our
home with brother and brother who
certain times is back
so basically today's topic is going to
be about envy and jealousy how to
overcome it every every single one of us
suffer from it there's no doubt about
that but today's topic is about how we
deal with that
so before I start with a prince on a
sonnet Allah the most merciful the most
gracious or praises worrying that should
belong to him so before I want to go
straight to Musa what's up do you have
you ever suffer from what I'm sure you
have but how do you yourself deal with
it you know when you are when you are
jealous of me you know like how do you
deal with them be like I want to be
handsome like when whenever I felt like
any hint of jealousy or anything like
that what I've done to myself literally
and Volare this is what I've done when
I've just felt a hint of it coming in
like from the shaitaan it's from the
shaitaan because I'm sure all of us wish
good for each other yes in our you know
from our fitrah but um whenever I
thought some sort of jealousy towards
someone for having something that I
would want or something that I really
like what I like to do is I like to look
at what they have and I force myself to
feel happy for them
so I think to myself first I think to
myself Musa you're not like that you
wish good for people and you know what
you should be happy that that person's
got that and mush or like you know
inshallah one day you'll have it as well
no problem and I try and force myself
lie in a bad way but a train like
basically put on myself feel happy for
that person and hamdullah whenever I do
it works I I'm not feeling happy for
that person yeah and I have a clean
heart towards that person obviously I
has happening to me in a possibly not yo
that's mad I want that but obviously at
the end of the day that's what I try and
do I try and personal ease condition
myself when I see someone have something
that I want I just try and think you
know good of them and provocative rabo
Abdul Aziz
basically this is just the way I do it
I'm gonna get this out of the way so
then I leave all to the Provost yeah so
basically the way I deal with it is
basically the freeways of found of
effective for me and maybe you got to
try as well when I have any bad thoughts
or envy or jealousy
well another person the first thing I
would say like all the denomination's I
know Jim I would seek refuge in Allah
from the cursed Shaytan because these
are the West westerns of Shaytan and its
technology yourself that no this is not
from me I don't like I'm happy you know
the second thing I do is I say o Allah
every time every time I think bad about
this person or in women jealous make me
jealous of him increase him in rank and
increase him in everything that he's got
that it's better to know you know that's
the second thing that I do and the third
thing that I do is I try to speak good
of this prophet in public places and
stuff like that just so it's better for
me is just a way of dealing with these
are the three things that I do I wish I
find is very effective you know so once
again seeking refuge in Allah making
what about every time you are envious of
him or jealous of that person that Allah
increases that person in rank in this
act in the hereafter and talking good
about the brother or sister in a
Katherine you know this is me personally
so please tell us what how do you deal
with the law officer Navarro pseudonym
about submitting your hemolysis nobody
is free from jealousy and everybody has
it we're lacking and emo
you did what Karim your fear except for
the less generous one the good person
yeah he has that jealousy but the wicked
one it shows in that hurt yeah never see
something that that that a lost battle
has just blessed your brother with a
good job with a good car is someone
who's prosperous McClarty all Margit
bless him oh allah azzawajal increase
him for example if a sister for example
if you see a large it has given us your
friend many kids and she don't really
walk mic'ed off and brother if you see
your friend is really prosper enroll his
kids are all martial are very good her
father make draw from him
wiped off and what because if you made
glad for your brother then everyone make
law for you
the Andrew McAfee and subhanallah spin
rated the mr. so seldom one day he was
in the messages and a person went to the
mistress and then promised awesome said
a person known to this mission from an
agenda he said it for three nights so of
the lot more than a sort of the Ilan
Hall he wanted to know what is the
Sahaba in general
yeah and briefly after I've been I've
been alas
yeah and he was known to pray like do
everything the Salah this is a man who
would practice the religion to the core
he's surprised of this man's why the why
the why the problem specific scene that
he wanted to know why he engine yes
so he said Tim Alcorn I will spend the
night with you yes so for three nights
he was with him he didn't see anything
special for misery bother meaning you
would pay his son just basically no and
his workshop was normal then he said oh
cool
the mr.justice insecure and Jenna what
is why is it that your engender
user dollar I don't really know so of
the lot number of nos he was
disappointed
then he walked away he said come come
here I don't know nothing except every
night before asleep I don't have any
jealousy no envy and no hatred or no
grudge in my heart against the believers
he said Allah Akbar this is what made
you enter the gender and this thing we
can yeah we cannot what's the code the
game handle this it's difficult for us
meaning that you know you might not
for example knife you might not have any
jealousy in your heart or somebody but
to give up the grudges and you know this
kind of difficult for you know somehow
love that yeah I need how would you say
they should like what would you think
they should concentrate on doing good
fight that well my number one is like I
said make it are for the person knowing
that maybe a lot as origin has blessed
you with something
and yes and blessed him for supper last
blessed him with money but follow
blessed you with health Allah has
blessed America but but all the students
are not bad so look at your blessings
yeah look at your bless us and sometimes
what people fall into is they have this
misjudgment of other people I'm gonna
give an example I'll give the example
I'm not imagining
walking down the street your life is not
going how you want it - I want it to be
you know it was also submit I will talk
a lot whatever the situation were in
imagine you see a guy driving a Range
Rover and he's got a pretty woman next
to him yet you know I want that life is
about a nice long look at video next to
him
look I needs happy why am I not happy
but there's some times we well sometimes
we don't understand that you imagine you
making it or although like I want to be
like him and imagine did this seem guy
has got cancer is when a dying too much
time the woman next to me is auntie and
the cars rented her lungs so what it
does is you're looking at force in
prison and you're making to us yet all
that make him like me even if it was
answered you got cancer so the thing is
sometimes what we do is we look at other
people's life and think is good it's one
happy days it's not everyone is tested
in different ways but this is why we
need to understand that we need to be
content within ourself once you find
that you happens within yourself and
submit your will to our land say
although whatever you give me I'm happy
with and you don't live for the people
that's when shooting at happiness hits
inside you and this a reminder to me
first interest because I'm a victim to
this sometimes as well you know if I got
to be honest so this is really important
we shouldn't live for other people to
clear skies I'm gonna ask you guys to
wrap it up it's been how long does it be
it's been who that eight minutes so I
was you any last points that you would
want to touch upon
shall I say something shoved on a fuss
over to another more sir barok Alavi
Khan Osama I think these bombers awesome
subdued stuff stupidly for every person
that's bliss or something is envied me
that's Allah Azza WA JAL for example
mashallah you you have a happy marriage
well that Allah has ordered has blessed
you with a good job we have lots of
goodness yeah don't tell it to others
why because you could be every bite
force upward you know you see Oh Masha
Allah I've a good wife I have a good job
my whole life is good and he's havin a
miserable life because what is the thing
from Ali bent and he said don't speak
about having a child for him stay here
next to a person quite I'm a child well
marriage about next to a person who
doesn't get married you know it's about
thinking about them you know you know
Bibi understand now you know they're
going through a struggle and you're
robbing in their face yeah and you're
gonna call them tonight
I want a human beings
also the poet says hostile Fattah if the
Lamia know to sell you who fell down the
ho ho somos cover oil has now clearly
what yeah hazard involved on in the
horrid anymore
they envied the way what did the enemy
the workmen because they cannot reach
his status this this individual he was
more successful of them afterwards the
people decide to hate him what because
this person he was more what's the code
they're successful of them also the poet
also says this but allocated hazard
famous opera Ocotillo be patient upon
the plot of the envious person for
verily your patient kills him just like
the fire it eats itself if it doesn't
have nothing else to eat subhanAllah so
professor Salim said the disease of the
previous nations has come to you where
is it and hasn't well bhava jealousy
envy and hatred of one another and also
another thing is you have to read you
ask are your morning even reminders so
Muslim Muslim for brother brothers to
pray or what's the code again your
fridge and Gemma so that you know
particular stuff from dying I hit you by
check this out yeah so I'm looking at
this here I'm like why do all of these
people outside do all of this like why
are we normally jealous because we feel
like what someone else's got we won it
but you see one of the things that I
learned yeah is that we have to be
content with what we have because at the
end of the day bro whatever you have
it's what's best for you it's what Allah
has predestined for you and that's
what's best for you honestly speaking so
like if you haven't got those shoes that
you want or anything like that that's
because it's not best for you it's not
as if invited to provisions yes of
course 100% mean there's nothing you can
do about that and if you're not content
with what you have right now then you
will never be content even if you get
that Ferrari
you're gonna be looking at someone else
you're always gonna be looking at other
people that's what I found myself doing
because a key like five years ago the
situation that I'm in right now would
dream to be him and now why is it
strange it's nothing and then in five
years
situation that I want to be in in five
years I'm probably gonna be in in five
years and then I'm so be gonna look at
the next phase of discipline it's like
as human beings we are never content
we're always looking at something else
yeah it's like it's that thing you know
that saying give the son of Adam a
mountain of God he'll want another one
and then you'll want another one it's in
our nature so I feel like what we need
to condition our software is to be
content with what you have
well lie if you're content with what you
have then you'll find it hard to feel
generous overview so guys thanks for
watching I hope you guys benefited do
implement what you've heard from us boil
a [ __ ] Lohan come ticket sir
Steve list estate ballast so this is
very less than state balance monocle
offical I said I want my Tory Medicare
to don't forget to check out is our ha
oh god it couldn't get a shot at the
hata TV we're gonna get a shout out to
party Lee please block them on YouTube
okay Joe couple hi to TVs well we'll put
the link at the end